what works and what doesn't about
Twitter if there's something that's
broken how would you fix it a million
things I can say here so a few things
first is fact checking I had this kind
of fun I thought it was a funny tweet to
anyone who wants to quote ban lying on
social media please write down a
function that takes in a statement and
returns whether it is true if you can
start with the remand hypothesis that
would be amazing yeah okay yeah not put
that's kind of funny right that's funny
and uh so now thank you that joke
landed on like five people sure if you
want to explain the shortcut well no I
there's a lot of problems decidability
where the truth that's what proofs in
math is the truth of the thing is
actually exceptionally difficult to
determine and that's just a really nice
example the problems that persist across
centuries that have not been solved in
the most Brilliant Minds they're
essentially true or false problems
that's right and so when people are
saying when they were saying they want
to ban lying on social media fact check
social media the assumption is that they
know what is true and what do they mean
by that they really mean the assertion
of political power right
with that said do I think it could be
useful to have some kind of quote factor
I can think yes but it has to be
decentralized and open source you could
imagine an interesting concept of coding
trugle like a Google that return was
true it's like a modified version right
it's like gpt3 but the stable diffusion
version where it's open
okay and so now anybody Stables Fusion
shows that it's possible to take an
expensive AI model and put it out there
right so you have you know you don't a
knowledge graph is like like basically
you know uh you wouldn't actually uh
whether you have it as rdf or like a
like a triple store kind of thing or
some other representation it's like an
ontology of a is a b and you know B has
a c and it's got probabilities on the
edges sometimes and other kinds of
metadata and this allows Google to show
certain kinds of one box information
where it's like
um what is so what is Steve Jobs's uh
you know what is what is Laureen Powell
Jobs's uh age or birthday they can pull
that up out of the out of the um the
knowledge graph right and uh so you can
imagine that true goal would have both
deterministic and statistical components
and crucially it would say whether
something is true according to a given
Knowledge Graph
and so this way at least what you can do
is you can say okay here's the things
that are consensus reality like the
value of the gravitational constant will
be the same in the Maga Knowledge Graph
and the US establishment Knowledge Graph
and the CCP Knowledge Graph and the the
I don't know the resilient Knowledge
Graph and so on and so forth okay but
there's other things that will be quite
different
and at least now you can isolate where
the point of disagreement is and so you
can have a form of decentralized fact
checking that is like according to who
well here is the authority and it is
this knowledge graph right so that's
like a kind of thing right yeah yeah so
that is
um so that's one concept of like what
next social media looks like there's
there's actually so much more another
huge thing is decentralized social media
okay social media today is like China
under communism in a really key sense
there's a great article called The
Secret document that transformed China
do you know what China was like before
1978 I know about the atrocities sure so
but there put some flesh on the yeah
bone so to speak okay
so basically there's a good book on me
because I think a lot of documents
became public recently and so there's a
window when it opened up now it's
probably closing back down again but but
you know great biographies because of
that were written like I'm currently
reading miles grade famine by Frank de
Carter yeah which is uh
whoo boy
it's crazy okay yeah here's the thing is
capitalism was punishable by Death
in living memory in China just to
explain what that meant okay I mean
that's what communism was right it was
literally the same China that has like
the CC you know the entrepreneurs and
Jack Ma and so on and so 40 something
years ago capitalism was punishable by
death what to put to give in a concrete
example there this is a famous story in
China maybe apocryphal but it's what you
know the folks have talked about there's
a village in xiaogang and basically all
the green that you were produced was
supposed to go to the collective and
even one straw belonged to the group at
one meeting with Communist Party
officials a farmer asked what about the
teeth in my head do I own those answer
no your teeth belong to the collective
okay now the thing is uh that when
you're taking a hundred percent of
everything okay work hard don't work
hard everyone gets the same so people
don't want to work right so what
happened
these Farmers gathered in secret and
they did something that was like would
have gotten them executed they they were
a contract amongst themselves and said
we all agree that we will be able to
keep some of our own grain we will give
some of them to the regime so when it
comes to Collective grain they've got
something we'll be able to keep some of
it and if any of us are killed for doing
this then the contract said that the
others would take care of their children
okay so to keep some of what you earned
I mean just think about how it performed
the many capitalism Society within the
company a secret cap of some Society so
what happened amongst five people yeah
right so now that they could keep some
of what they earned right earned they
had a bumper Harvest and you know what
happened with that bumper Harvest that
made the local officials really
suspicious and mad they weren't happy
that there was a bumper Harvest they're
like what are you doing you're doing
capitalism right and in you know a few
years earlier they might have just been
executed and in fact many were that's
what it means when you see Millions dead
Millions dead means guys were shot for
keeping some grain for themselves okay
it means like guys came and kicked in
the door of your Collective farm and you
know raped your wife and took you off to
a prison camp and so forth that's what
communism actually was okay it hasn't
been depicted in movies there's a great
post um by Ken Billingsley in in the
year 2000 called uh I got this right
Hollywood's missing movies
okay this is um
basically here I'll paste this links you
put in the show notes all right this is
worth reading it's still applicable
today but now that we have stable
diffusion now we have all these people
online now that Russia and China are
America's national bad guys
um you know as they were before they are
again perhaps we'll get some movies on
what communism actually was during the
twin century and how bad it was right
and you know vaccinate people against
that as well as against Nazism which
they should be okay the point of this uh
go ahead uh no because I'm I'm
congratulating myself on the nice
because you're sending me excellent
links on WhatsApp and I just saw that
there's an export chat feature yes great
because we also have disappear messages
on so I was like all right this is great
great I'll be able to get it this your
your ability to reference sources is
incredible so thank you for this anyways
otherwise if I if I say something it
sounds too surprising so that's why I
want to make sure I have it on this top
yeah so like yeah I mean people would be
like shot for for holding some grain so
what happened though was
ding Xiaoping
said okay
um we're not going to kill you in fact
we're going to actually set up the first
special economic zone in Shenzhen he
didn't try to flip the whole country
from communist to capitalist in one go
and said he's like we can reform in one
place
and in fact he fenced it off from the
rest of China and it did trade with Hong
Kong and he spent his political capital
on this one exception it grew so fast
that gave him more political Capital you
know some people think actually that the
you know sino-vietnamese War uh was
deng's way of just distracting the
generals while he was turning China
around to get it back on the capitalist
Road and what he did was
um the opposite of a rebranding he did a
reinterpretation like a rebranding is
where the substance is the same but the
logo is changed okay you know you're now
you were Facebook you're now meta that's
a rebranding right
reinterpretation is where the logo and
The Branding is the same they're still
the CCP they're still the Chinese
Communist party but they're capitalist
now the engine under the hood it's
deniable okay and this is a very common
once you realize those are different
things it's like swap the front end swap
the back end yeah
go ahead go ahead put it right it's
really good yeah yeah
enjoying your metaphors and way of
talking about stuff yes I get yeah yeah
swap you could yeah we're branding and
swap the front end reinterpretation swap
the back end that's right once you you
know once you realize that you're like
okay I can just like as an engineer you
can kind of okay sometimes I want to do
this on the front end sometimes under
the back end sometimes this is explicit
and sometimes user doesn't need to see
it and it's on the back end lots of
political stuff uh you know is arguably
not just best done on the back end but
always done on the back end one of the
points I make in the book is left is the
new right is a new left is
um you know if you look through history
the the Christian King the Republican
conservative the CCP entrepreneur
um the um the WASP establishment these
are all examples of a revolutionary left
movement becoming the ruling class right
okay like the Republican conservative
just is that one example I go through
extend description of this in the book
but the Republicans were the The Radical
Republicans the left of 1865 they won
the Revolution and their moral Authority
LED them to have economic Authority in
the late 1800s you wouldn't want a
Democrat Confederate Trader as the head
of your you know Railroad Company would
you right so all the Confederate traders
that were boxed out from the plum
positions in the late 1800s uh and so
what happened was the Republicans turned
their moral Authority into economic
Authority made tons of money the
Democrats then started repositioning not
as a party of the Southern racist but
the the poor right and you know the
cross of gold speech by William James
Brown was part of that there's a gradual
process that reaches apart let's say a
crucial Mark with the election of FDR
whereas actually not the 1932 but 1936
election that uh black voters switched
over to FDR okay that was actually the
the like the major flip to like 70 you
know to to to the Democrats now they've
reposition it as a party the poor not
the party of the South okay and
Republicans
had lost
um some economic Authority or rather
they had moral authority to turn into
economic Authority they started to lose
some moral Authority the loss of moral
30 was complete by 1965. that was
actually mop-up people dated you know
the Civil Rights Movement as a big way
where the Republicans lost morality it's
not really that was a mop-up because uh
1936 30 years earlier was when black
voters switched to the Democrats okay
1765 was another 10 points moving over
of black voters to Democrats Roland said
completely lost moral Authority 100
years after the Civil War okay then the
next 50 years
that loss of moral Authority meant that
they lost economic Authority because now
you wouldn't want a republican bigot as
a c of your tech company anymore would
you right so by 2015 2020 now now you
have it's like two sine waves that are
staggered right moral Authority leads to
economic Authority leads to loss of uh
moral Authority leads to loss of
economic Authority and so now you have
the uh the Democrats you know have you
know completed 155-year Arc from the
defeated party in the Civil War to
the dominant party in the US
establishment all the woke capitalists
are now at the very top and now the same
repositioning is happening where if
you're so woke why are you rich
you get it right like you know if you're
so smart why aren't you rich is the
normal kind of thing right if you're so
woke if you're so holy why is like for
example the BLM founder why do they have
this million dollar mansion right if
you're so woke and it's all about being
good and you're anti-capitalist how come
you seem to be raking in the money Etc
right
this is an argument which I'm not sure
how long it will go
um it might take years to play out might
take decades to play out I think
probably on the order of a decade you're
going to see in my view the
repositioning if the Democrats are the
world capitalists the Republicans will
eventually become are becoming the
Bitcoin maximalists why because
you know if one guy picks left the other
guy picks right it's literally like
magnets kind of repelling they're sort
of forced into the other corner here
right in the Bitcoin Maximus will
essentially where this guy says
centralization they say decentralization
where they defend the right of capital
to do anything the maximalist will say
actually you're all cantillionaires
um you're all benefiting from printed
money you don't have anything that's
legitimate you don't actually own
anything is all a handout from the
government and so on and so forth right
and um so that's the counter positioning
that will basically attack the wokes by
how much money they're making they're
not contesting the ideology so when one
guy signals economics you signal culture
when uh their guy signals culture you
signal economics that's actually that's
the whole thing I can talk about should
I talk about that for a second sure is
is this uh integrated into the forces
that you talk about
you've talked about the three forces
that Trifecta forces that affect our
society which is the wokes let's say
what
and I think so slow no no no uh woke
Capital communist capital and crypto
capital
uh can you explain each of those three
we actually talked about each of the
three in part but it'd be nice to bring
them together in a beautiful triangle
and then I will also come back up and
I'll talk about how the CCP story
relates to social media and
decentralized social media okay all
right so nyt CCP BTC is
what capital communist Capital crypto
capital and communist capital is the
simplest is you must submit the
Communist party is powerful CCP is
powerful and you are not if you're in
China you just CCP is an embodiment of
communist Capital that you're talking
about well yeah so basically and by the
in China they call it CPC you know so
basically they don't like it usually if
you say CCP right so uh like Communist
Party of China as opposed to Chinese
kind of sort of there basically that is
capitalism that is uh that it's a
Chinese pool of capital that billion
person pool okay that that's WeChat and
it's
um you know it's Alibaba and its entire
kind of thing that is one just social
network with currency the whole thing is
vertically interested when we say
communist what do you mean here why is
the word communist important why don't
you just say China so it's it's
communist an important way well it's
just a catchy label it's a catchy level
but I think it's also important because
it seems It's paradoxical right so I had
a threat on this the future is communist
Capital versus Capital versus crypto
Capital each represents a left right
Fusion that's Bizarre by the standards
of the 1980s consensus it's PRC versus
mmt versus BTC all right and why is it
Bizarre by the standards of 1980s
consensus well in the 1980s you wouldn't
think the Communists would become
capitalists but they did you wouldn't
think that the wokes the progressives
right
um would become so enamored with giant
corporations and and their power right
they've seen something to like in that
right
um and you also wouldn't think that the
non-americans or the post-americans or
the internationalists would be the
champions of capital because
you think it's the American Nation right
so rather than the conservative American
nationalists
being the Defenders of capital
you have the
liberal
Americans who are with capital you have
the Communist Chinese or with capital
and you have the internationalists who
are with capital and it's the
conservative American nationalists who
are in some ways against that which is
which is kind of funny right so uh so
it's like this weird ideological
flipping that
um if you if you look if you take the
long lens you have these polls that kind
of repel each other okay so just on the
CCP nyt BTC thing
nyt by the way is Wolf Capital yeah what
is nyt so its formula is a little
interesting if CCP is just you must
submit because they're powerful okay and
then you bow your head because the
Chinese Communist party is strong well
capital is you must sympathize why do
you bow your head Lex oh because you're
a white male therefore you're guilty you
sympathize you must bow your head
because you are powerful
yet notice it ends in the same place in
your your head looking to the ground
right in China it's because they are
powerful so therefore you must bend your
head
for the Bogues it's the left-handed
version where you are powerful and
that's shameful so you should bow your
head
right right okay but it ends in your
head bowed it's an ideology of
submission it's not that subtle but it's
like somewhat subtle and then finally
crypto capital is head held high you
must be sovereign
okay which and one of the things I point
out in the in the book is each of these
polls is
um negative in some ways when taken to
extreme but also negative in its
opposite for example
obviously just totally submitting to
Total surveillance is bad but a society
where nobody submits is San Francisco
where people just Rob stores and walk
out you know in the middle shoplifting
you know all this all these goods and
nothing happens right a society where
you know you have the vocal level of
sympathy where you get to the kind of
insanity of math is white supremacist
and whatever you know nonsense is is
happening today is terrible but a
society that's totally stripped of
sympathy is also not one that one would
want to be part of right that's just
like the
you know whether it's 4chan's actual
culture or its Fame culture or something
like that or some some weird combination
you that's also not good it's like
Russia in the 90s like nobody trusts
anybody that's also bad
and you know being totally Sovereign
that sounds good and there's a lot that
is good about it and I'm sympathetic to
this corner but being totally Sovereign
you go so capitalist so Sovereign that
you're against the division of labor you
don't trust anybody so you have to pump
your own water and so on so you actually
have a reduced standard of living over
here okay
and conversely like survivalist or
whatever survivalist type stuff right
and you just kind of you you just go
kind of too crazy into that corner and
then like of course though the Other
Extreme of you know having no
sovereignty is the you will own nothing
and be happy everything's in the cloud
and can be deleted at any point right so
each of these is kind of has Badness
when it's there but also it's total
extreme opposite is bad and so you want
to kind of carve out like an intelligent
intermediate of these three poles and
that's the you know decentralized Center
or the recentralized center I call it
now with that said
I think there is a repositioning in
particular of vote Capital that is
happening and I think if the 2000s was
the global war on terror and then the
channel just changed to wokeness in the
2010s and I mean channel change have you
seen Paul Graham's graph or actually
David rosado's graph that Paul Graham
posted no but this is a good chance to
say that Paul Graham is awesome okay
yeah and so here is this graph okay
David rosado's data analysis I think
that put this together so but basically
this is a graph of the word usage
frequency New York Times 1970 to 2018
and he's got some controls there Paul
Graham tweets hypothesis although some
newspapers can survive the switch to
online subscriptions none can do it and
remain politically neutral quote
newspaper or record you have to pick a
side to get people to subscribe and
there's uh a bunch of
plots
on the x-axis is years on the y-axis is
the frequency of use
and sexism has been going up misogyny
has been going up sexist
patriarchy Mass planning toxic
masculinity male privilege all these
terms have been going up
very intensely in the past in in the in
the past decade yeah but really 2013 is
the exact moment you see these things
they're flat and they just go vertical
mansplaining toxic masculinity what
precisely happen in 2013. ah so
I talked about this in the book but I
think fundamentally what happened was
Tech hurt media and their revenue
dropped by uh about 50 billion dollars
over the four years from oh 2012. Tech
helped Obama get reelected and media was
positive on on Tech until December 2012
they wrote like the Nerds Go Marching In
in the Atlantic then after January 2013
once Obama was enconced then the knives
came out because basically these Tech
guys were bankrupting them they were
through
um supporting them and so the journals
got extremely nasty and uh just
basically they couldn't build search
engines or create social networks but
they could write stories and shape
narrators so clear editorial Direction
went down that
um you know essentially took all of this
all these weapons that had been
developed in Academia to win status
competitions and Humanities departments
yeah and and then they just deployed
them right and essentially somebody
observed that wokeness is the
combination of uh focality and
deconstruction and civil rights where
deconstruction takes away you know the
legitimacy of the old order and then
civil rights says okay the only thing
that's good is is this right which is
says the older is also bad in a
different way but this is what's good
and um
that is the underpinning ideology the
the all these words have embedded in
them like in ideology right a number of
thinking about it is
this is not my reference but I'll cite
It Anyway the glossary of the Greek
um military Junta right the creation and
or use of special terms are employed by
the juntas propaganda tools
um because essentially the word itself
embeds a concept you can wrestle
conjugate something one way or the other
right Russell conjugation is a concept
that I sweat you perspire but She Glows
you can always take something you know
you are uncontrollably angry but uh he
is righteously indignant okay
um you have a thin skin they clap back
right so once you kind of realize that
these words have just been chosen in
such a way as to delegitimize their
Target and they all went vertical in
2013 and they were suddenly targeted
against the erstwhile alleys you know in
Tech but also just across the the
country you can see that this great
awokening that's what uh Iglesias called
it by plan where it's the Great
Awakening right this kind of spasm of
quasi-religious extremism I wouldn't
call it religious because it's not
god-centered it's release date and
network centered so I call it a Doctrine
which is a superset of religion and
political Doctrine this uh these words
went vertical and the all the terrorism
stuff you just noticed kind of fell off
a cliff that was the obsession of
everything in the 2000s
and just channel change right it's
amazing how that happened yeah it's not
like not like any of the pieces got
picked up some of those Wars are still
raging of course and there's uh victims
to this wilkism movement and um but in a
weird way even though some parts of it
just like you know Siri like there's
wars in the Middle East that still keep
raging there's there's certainly active
fronts of focusum you know but in a
sense the the next shift is already on
you know why
it's a pivot for mochism to statism
in many ways nyt is sort of and more
generally the U.S establishment is sort
of kind of coming you may not believe
this they're kind of coming back to the
center a little bit and the same with
that Lenin After the revolution
implemented the New Economic Policy
which you may be aware of right which
was just like X percent more capitalism
you kind of boot on the neck take
control but then ease up for a bit and
the so-called net men during the 20s
were able to eke out something there was
like you know oh okay fine he's going to
be easier on us then an intense fight
again because basically by loosening up
they were able to consolidate control
they weren't putting as much pressure on
right then it went extremely intense
again right uh similar to like Mao's
like 100 flowers saying let a hundred
flowers bloom and you know everybody
came out and then you found out all the
people who were against him and he
executed a bunch of them right so what's
happening now is nyt is and more
generally just establishment is somewhat
tacking back to the center where you
know they're not talking BLM and abolish
the police they're saying fund the
Capitol Police right they've they've
gone from The Narrative of 2020 which
was meant to win a domestic contest
where they said America's a systemically
racist country tear down George
Washington we're so evil to the red
record 2022 which is we're the global
champion of democracy and every
non-white country is supposed to trust
us
now
obviously those are inconsistent right
if if you're in India or you're in
Nigerian you just heard that the America
is calling itself the same guys by the
way saying it's so institutionally
racist systemically racist and you're
saying well we're the leader of the Free
World and the number one obviously
there's inconsistency between the
domestic propaganda and the foreign
propaganda right there's a contrast
between abolish the police and put two
billion for the capital police you can
reconcile this and you can say
the use establishment is pro-federal and
anti-local and state so abolish the
local police who tend to be you know
Republican or rightist but fund the FBI
fund the capital police who tend to be
you know just like in the
um you know Soviet Union as a national
things like the the KGB right that were
there for the um uh for the state
um but there are all these local
nationalist ethnic insurgencies and like
Estonia and other places right so you
can reconcile them but nevertheless on
its face those those are contradictory
so what are you going to get I think I
think you're going to get
um this rotation where uh a fair number
of the folks on the sort of
authoritarian right are kind of pulled
back into the fold a bit okay these are
the cops and the military and whatnot
some of them because as this decade
progresses you're going to see the
signaling on American statism as opposed
to bookism okay which is 30 degrees back
towards the center right conversely on
the other side you're going to have the
left Libertarians and right Libertarians
who are signaling crypto and
decentralization and so on okay and so
the next one isn't red versus blue it's
Orange versus green it's a dollar versus
Bitcoin and so you have the
authoritarians the top of the political
Compass versus the quote Libertarians
right and here is the here's the visual
of that
so that's why like you know as I wrote
the book and after I was like you know
I'm already seeing this
um this shift happening from war on
terror to bokism to American statism
right and here just take a look at this
visual
interesting so uh the visual is an
animation transforming
the
left versus right libertarian versus
authoritarian to uh
Bitcoin dollar versus versus crypto
that's right and some folks switch sides
right because you have folks Like You
Know Jack Dorsey and a lot of the tech
Founders in basically the lower left
corner right who were blue but are now
going to become orange or are orange and
you have folks in the upper right corner
who are going to at the end of the day
pick the dollar and the American flag
over the internationalist ideals of
cryptocurrency the realigning as you
call it let me ask you uh I the briefly
we do need to get a a comment your
Visionary view of things
we're at a low point in the
cryptocurrency space from a shallow
analysis perspective or maybe in a
deeper sense if you can enlighten me do
you think Bitcoin will rise again yes do
you think you'll go uh to take on
Fiat you know to go over a million
dollars to go to these Heights I mean I
think it's possible and the reason I
think it's possible is I think a lot of
things might go to a million dollars
because inflation is inflation right
it's an important point right it's a
very important Point yes because you're
seeing essentially
yes but so the choke pointing on energy
is pushing of prices across the board
for a lot of things the supply you know
China's not doing us any favors with the
covid uh lockdowns
um Putin's not doing the world any
favors with this with this giant War
um there's a lot of bad things happening
in the physical world right you know you
have
I mean when China Russia and the US are
all and Europe is you know like there's
folks who are just insane about degrowth
and they're against
um you know they're they're they're
they're pushing for burning coal and
wood right so a lot of prices are going
up in a really foundational and
fundamental way and um with that said
also the dollar is in some ways
strengthening against certain other
things because a lot of other countries
are dying harder right
um you know and you've got riots in Sri
Lanka and riots and Panama and riots in
you know all these places right so it's
it's very complicated because you've got
multiple different Trends going in the
same way you're you're Bitcoin Maximus
would just say infinity over 21 million
and so therefore you print all the
dollars there's only 200 million
Bitcoins so Bitcoin goes to Infinity but
it can be something where lots of other
currencies die and the dollar is
actually exported via stable coins okay
um but I do think it still moves Fiat
still moves somehow into the
cryptocurrencies yeah yeah it's I think
it's kind of like Microsoft where and
windows is still around right I'm
actually still around still a you know
multi 100 billion dollar company it
doesn't mean it he doesn't mean it don't
worry all my machines are windows are
they still boot yeah okay okay I don't
know a single Mech really okay that you
are unusual on that yeah that's um so at
least for hours it's not an ideology
just convenience fine I mean they
actually now post out there they do make
some good stuff right like uh Microsoft
teams is good right like there's a lot
of stuff and UCO has done a lot of
innovative things like GitHub yeah let
me built this in acquisition but still
does that give them credit for the
acquisition the pivoting of vision and
motivations and uh focus and all that
kind of stuff anyway yes Microsoft does
an analogy metaphor for something well
yeah so basically just like you know
they didn't need a turnaround but they
are they did endure to the present day
they didn't die from Google app I mean
for the massive attacks on them they
didn't die they are less powerful but
they make more money right yes and um
I think that might be something that I
mean our best case scenario is the use
establishment or CCP has more power over
fewer people
okay I see and so you know but you can
exit if you if you're there you're kind
of knuckling under or whatever but you
can't exit right and so I mentioned the
uh those three polls CCP is obviously a
billion people 1.4 aligned under the
digital Yuan and so on right nyt is the
entire you know it's it's the tech
companies it's the US dollar it is the
assessor and then crypto capital is
everybody else but I actually think that
over time
that third world is web 3 this time and
that's the third poll and that's India
and it's Israel and it's lots of
American conservatives and left
Libertarians and Libertarians and it's
also lots of Chinese liberals all the
folks who are trying to get out of China
because you know the like the you know
it's become so Nationalist and crazy and
difficult for capitalism and so if you
take basically non-establishment
Americans on both left and right okay
the the you know the bottom two
quadrants in the political Compass I
talked about you take the liberal
Chinese you take the Israelis and the
Indians why because they don't both of
them are have a lot of tech Talent right
they're the number one and number two
demographics for Tech founders and they
want to uh while they are generally
sympathetic to the West right and
they're more ties to the West they also
are more cautious about national
interests rather than just starting
fights you know where that's how they
would think about it right they just you
know India thinks it's a poor country
Israel thinks of itself as a small
country and so therefore it needs to not
just get in every fight just for the
sake of it and so you need to maintain a
cautious distance with China but not
like do what Pelosi is doing and try and
start like a big thing okay
I think Israel is similar where it's
maintaining diplomatic relations with
China it's more friendly towards China
than the US's Indian Israel I think are
two sovereign states that have a lot of
globally mobile tech talent that
obviously have ties to the West with the
large diaspora that are hard to demonize
you know in around the sense of
willing to argue on the internet
let's put it like in English right it's
very important and
um them plus enough Americans plus
enough Chinese can stand up another poll
that is not for Cold War or military
confrontation but for peace and trade
and freedom and so on and so forth right
that's the center
as opposed to the you know left of the
you know the the woke American U.S
establishment or the right of the ultra
nationalist CCP right that's what I
think about now what I would say here is
the reason I think these are the kind of
the three polls you can argue against
this right you can say it's unipolar
World America is totally dominant that's
one argument you could say it's a
bipolar world it's just the US versus
China no no everybody else will have to
be forced to align with one or the other
geoshunker you know actually explicitly
rejected this he's like look there's a
billion people in India it's coming up
on it will eventually be like the number
three economy it's on the rise
he's got the history and culture he
thinks he's entitled to have India's
Intel to have its own side right in such
a thing it's a funny way of putting it
right yeah but it's also true and uh so
you could say it's unipolar you could
say it's bipolar you could say it's just
multi-polar and everybody is kind of
their you know India Israel these groups
are out there but I actually think it's
going to be tripolar the reason it's
tripolar is these three pools are the
groups that have enough media and money
and scale and whatnot to really kind of
be self-consistent civilizations
obviously China's like the vertically
integrated like apple or whatever just
like it might be a stable ideology a
stable ideology that's right right
obviously the you know the books have
control of lots of Institutions they've
got the US establishment and they've got
the tech companies got the media
companies and so on but crypto is
basically everybody else and crucially
crypto has inroads in China and America
where it's hard to demonize it as
completely foreign because there's many
many many huge proponents of the
Universalist values of crypto in America
and China because it is
true Global rule of law and free speech
and you know so on it is genuinely
Universalist in a way where America can
no longer be you know the number one
rule of the rules-based order is
America's always number one and China
doesn't even pretend to maintain a
rules-based order right yes whereas for
all those countries that don't want to
either be dominated by the U.S media
corporations that can or social media
that can just censor Trump nor do they
want to be dominated by China this is an
attractive alternative a platform they
can make their own right so that's where
I think you know I wrote an article on
this in in foreign policy on um here
here's two articles that talk about this
a little bit it's called great protocol
politics and then here's another one on
these sort of domestic thing Bitcoin is
civilization for Barry Wise okay but I
want to just come up the stack a little
bit and just return to that original
point which I diverged on which was why
I gave the whole example of how uh
we got into China because I talked about
how China had gone from communist
capitalists and letting people have just
a share of what they owned right with
social media
we're still in kind of the Communist era
of social media almost where whatever
you earn on social media like Google
takes its cut Twitter takes 100 you're
nothing for all your tweets or anything
like that not only do you have do you
earn nothing
um you might get a little rev share on
Tick Tock or YouTube you can do okay
right but not only do you earn either
nothing or a little bit you have no
digital property rights even more
fundamentally you are at the just the
whim of a giant Corporation can hit a
button and everything you work for over
Years Gone okay that is even if that is
quote the current state of events the
State of Affairs rather that is not the
right balance of power
to be able to unperson somebody at the
touch of a key and take away everything
in their digital world when we're living
more and more in the digital world we
need to check on that power and the
check on that power is crypto and it's
property rights and it's
decentralization right and when I say
digital search and decentralization I
mean
your money and your digital property is
by default yours and there has to be a
due process to for someone to take that
away from you everything all work is
online all your money is online your
presence is online that can just be
taken away from you with a with the
Press of a key that just gives you know
bad governments bad corporations so much
power that that's wrong right that's why
I'm a medium and long-term Bull on
crypto simply because to check on this
thing and that if you think about in
terms of just abstract decentralizations
one thing but you think about in terms
of property rights it's quite another
and um
now what that also means is once you
have property rights and you have
decentralized social media it'll be like
the explosion of trade that happened
after China went from communist
capitalist literally billions of people
around the world are no longer giving
everything to the collective they own
the teeth in their head now finally
okay it's funny right so you're Lex
friedman.eath you own it the keys are on
your computer the bad part is of course
they can get hacked or something like
that then you can deal with that with
social recovery there's ways of securing
keys but the good part is ta-da uh you
actually have property rights in the
Hernando de Soto sense you have
something you own ownership digital
ownership it's the cloud is great but
crypto gives you some of the
functionality of the cloud
while also having some of the
functionality offline world where you
have the keys so it's a v it's a V3
right it's you know it's continuous
theme right the V1 was offline I've got
a key I own it I have de facto control
V2 is the cloud someone else manages it
for me it's hosted I get collaboration
so on V3 is the chain where you combine
aspects of those right you have the
global state of the cloud but you have
the local permission and controlling of
the private key okay so that's why I'm a
medium to long term Ultra Bull on crypto
and I've actually there's a podcast I
gave with a Simco where I talked through
how crypto actually doesn't just go
after Finance so it's gold and it's wire
transfers and it's crowdfunding and it's
all a finance with D5 but it's actually
also search and it's social and it's
messaging it's actually even operating
systems
um and uh and eventually cloud and
whatnot talk about that briefly yeah
yeah if you can prove if you see social
how broad you see the effect of crypto
so first crypto is fundamentally a new
way of building back-end systems right
so if you think about how big a deal it
was to go from at T's corporate Unix to
Linux it's permissionless right when you
went from as much as I admire a lot of
the stuff that you know Sam Altman and
Greg Brockman have done at open AI I
mean they're phenomenal in terms of
research they've pushed the envelope
forward I give them a ton of credit
right still it was great to see stable
diffusion out there which was open
source AI right and so from a developer
from a power user standpoint whenever
you have the unlocked version like an
unlocked cell phone it's always going to
be better right so
the um what crypto gives you obviously
it's every Financial thing in the world
you can do stocks bonds Etc it's not
just like the internet wasn't just a
Channel it wasn't like radio and TV and
internet it was internet radio and
internet TV and internet this and
internet that everything was the
internet all media became the internet
crypto is not an asset class it's all
asset classes it's crypto stocks and
crypto bonds Etc in a real sense like
private property arguably didn't exist
in the same way before crypto
international law didn't exist before
crypto how is how are you going to do a
deal between Brazil and Bangladesh
um if a Brazilian company wants to you
know acquire a Bangladeshi company they
usually have to set up a us adapter in
between because otherwise what are the
tax or the you know other obligations
between the two you set up a us adapter
or a Chinese adapter to go between them
but now that Brazilian embodization can
go peer-to-peer because they're using
blockchain right they can agree on a
system of law that is completely you
know International and that's code so
each party can diligence it without
speaking Portuguese and Bengali right so
that's why I am a long-term Bull on
crypto I just described the the finance
case let me go through the others right
social so
you have the private keys for your ens
you have apps like forecaster you um
basically have decentralized social
media where there's different variants
some you just log in with your crypto
username others the entire social
network and all the likes and posts are
on chain like DSO but uh but there's
several different versions right search
Once uh you know once you realize
um block explorers are an important
stealth threat to search they're very
high traffic sites like blockchain.com
and either scan that Google is just
totally slept on they don't have a block
Explorer you don't have to do anything
in terms of trading or anything like
that Google does not have a block
Explorer why they don't think of it as
search but it is search it's absolutely
searched it's a very important kind of
search engine and once you have crypto
social you have you now show that you're
not just indexing in a block Explorer
like uh on-chain transactions but on
chain Communications
okay so now you suddenly see oh the
entire Social Web that Google couldn't
index It could only index a worldwide
web and not the Social Web now it's
actually the on chain signed web because
every post is digitally signed it's a
new set of signals it's way easier to
index than either the World Wide Web or
the Social Web because open in public so
this is a total disruptive thing to
search in the medium term because the
new kind of data sets Index right
so that's how it's a threat to social to
search it is a threat to messaging why
because or it's disrupt eventually
because the ens name as I mentioned is
like a universal identifier you can send
encrypted messages between people that's
a better primitive to base it on you
know WhatsApp is just claiming that
they're end to end encrypted but with an
ens name or with a crypto name you can
be provably auditably and encrypted
because you're actually sending it back
and forth right because the private key
is local right that itself given how
important that is right you know you
could man in the middle signal or
Whatsapp because there's a server there
right if you have you know so n10
encrypted messaging will happen and with
payments and all this other stuff okay
so you get the crypto messaging apps you
get uh operating systems why well the
frontier of operating systems I mean
look you know Windows uh Linux and Mac
OS have been around forever but if you
actually think about you know what is a
blockchain
well there's operating systems there's
web browsers a blockchain is the most
complicated thing since an operating
system or whatever is because it's a
kind of operating system why it's got
you know something like ethereum has an
evm it's got a programming language it's
got an ecosystem where people monetize
on it they build front-end apps and they
build back-end apps they interoperate
between each other this is a frontier of
operating systems research people
haven't thought of it that way right
it's also the frontier of a lot of
things in databases
um you will get a crypto LinkedIn where
there's zero knowledge proofs of various
credentials okay uh basically every
single web 2 company I can probably come
up with a web 3 variant of it right like
ethereum is I mean and this is high
praise for both parties but ethereum is
like the crypto stripe prior to the
Webster stripe and you will
um you will see versions of every
everything else that are like this
but you know I kind of described uh
search social messaging operating
systems the phone right Salon is doing a
crypto phone why do you want that again
digital property apple is was talking
about running some script to find if
people were having you know csam like CH
you know child porn or whatever on their
on their phones right and even nyt
actually reported that uh like Google
ran something like this and found false
positive some guy had to take a photo of
a kid for our you know medical diagnosis
it got false you know falsely flagged I
see Sam he lost access to his account
total nightmare imagine just getting
locked out of your Google account which
you're so dependent on right as more and
more of your Digital Life Goes online
you know is it really that much
ethically different if it's the Chinese
state that locks you out or an American
corporation
right basically it's operationally very
similar you just have no recourse you're
unpersoned right so the crypto phone
becomes like insanely important because
you have a local set of private keys so
this was the keys to your currency and
your passport and your services and your
life right so like become something you
just hold on you with your person at all
times like your normal phone you might
have backups and stuff but you know the
crypto phone is an insanely important
thing okay and so that's search that's
social that's messaging that's
um operating systems that's a phone
that's a lot right there yeah that's
beautiful can I have 120 seconds to just
finish up a few more thoughts on social
media please okay AI and AR okay just
massive impact obviously of AI and
social media you're going to have
completely new social media companies
gestures other things you know Tick Tock
having you know some of the AI creation
Tools in there is is just like a V1 of
that
um this whole thread with everything
stable diffusion is unlocking but
basically this is going to melt
Hollywood Us Media corporations that
took a hit in the 2010s we're now going
to be able to have everyone around the
world able to tell their story and all
the stuff about AI ethics and AI bias
the ultimate bias is centralized AI
only decentralized AI is truly
representative you cannot be faux
representative you cannot claim that
some that Google is representing
Nigerians and Indians and Brazilians and
Japanese like those folks need to have
access themselves right so that's a
fundamental ethical argument against
centralized AI it's unethical and it's
like you know this faux thing where you
might have like faux diversity in the uh
in the interface but you haven't
actually truly decentralized it this is
the world capitalism right you justify
it with the bookness and you make the
money by centralizing it but the actual
way of doing it is letting it free for
the world and letting people build their
own versions if people want to build a
Asian Lord of the Rings they can do that
they want to build an Indian one they
can do that if they you know whatever
they want right so
that is the argument for
um Ai decentralization and for how that
kind of links to this I love that AI
decentralization fixes the bias problem
and AI which a lot of people seem to
yeah centralization talking about and
focus on yeah centralization is
inherently unrepresentative
fundamentally like you can like
mathematically show it it's not
representing the world
the the decentralization allows anybody
to pick it up and make it their own
right and centralization is almost
always a mask for like that private
corporate interest where it's like one
of the things about the vocabulism thing
by the way is the Deep platforming of
trump is was political other things are
political but you know what D
platforming started with in the late
2000s early 2010s all the open social
stuff was when D platform is being used
as a corporate weapon against meerkat
and Zynga and Teespring right these were
companies that were competing with
features of you know tweet deck et
cetera they're competing with features
of Twitter or Facebook and the API was
cut off and that was when actually
progressives were for net neutrality and
an open internet and open social against
the concentration of corporate power and
so on remember that right and uh so
what's going to happen is both those two
things the political and the corporate
are going to come together why in the
Soviet Union
denunciation was used as a tool to for
example undercut romantic Rivals right
there's a great article called practice
of denunciation in in you know the
Soviet Union right which talks about all
these examples where the ideological
argument was used to like kick somebody
into the 300 like pit that existed at
like the center of the Soviet Union
anybody could be kicked into the pit at
any moment and ta-da well Ivan's out you
know and now you know hey Anna you know
whatever right okay that same thing is
going to be used by what capitalist is
being used by vocabulous where the woke
argument is used to justify pulling
pushing their competitor out of the app
store or downracking them in search well
again you wouldn't want a a bigot to be
in search who could compete with us or
whatever right and conversely
um so so the wokeness is used to make
money and
um the money is used to advance the
ideology it's like this kind of back and
forth sometimes right now you think of
those as independent things but then
they fuse okay and so that's very clear
with the AI bias arguments where it just
so happens that it's so powerful Lex
this technology is so powerful in the
wrong hands it could be used so we will
charge you 9.99 for every use of it
how's that how altruistic is that is
that amazingly altruistic it's really
good right so
so once you kind of
um kind of see that as I said whenever
they're positioning in economics you can
go and culture when they're pushing on
culture you can go in economics if
they're so woke why are they Rich if
they're so concerned about
representation why is it centralized
answer they're not actually concerned
about it they're making money right okay
so that is I think in a few words blows
up a lot of the AI bias type stuff right
okay
um they're basically they're biasing AI
all right so the amount of stuff that
can be done with AI now like it also
helps the pseudonymous economy as I was
talking about with the AI Zoom so you
have totally new sites uh totally new
apps that are based on that
um it uh I think it may
um
I mean it changes you're going to have
new Google Docs you know all these kinds
of things you might have
um you know once you can do things with
just a few Taps you might have sites
that are focused more on producing
rather than just consuming because you
know you might with AI you can change
the productivity of gestures you know
you can have a few gestures like like a
for example the image to image thing
with the sale diffusion where you make a
little cartoon third graders painting
and it becomes a real painting a lot of
user interfaces will be rethought now
that you can actually do this incredible
stuff with the ad knows what you want it
to do right
so um and I saw this funny thing which
was a riff on Peter thiel's line which
is AI centralized and crypto is
decentralized and and somebody was
saying actually it turns out crypto
centralized with the cbdc's and stable
coin and so on but AI is getting
decentralized with stable diffusion haha
right which is funny and I think there's
centralized and decentralized versions
of each of these right and finally the
third poll that actually you know teal
uh you know he talks about Ai and crypto
but the third poll is actually that's
sort of underappreciated because people
think it already exists is social that
just keeping on going right and
obviously the next step in Social is AR
and VR and why is it so obvious because
it's meta you know it's Facebook now I
saw this very silly article it's like oh
my God Facebook is so dumb for putting a
10 billion dollars into you know virtual
reality right and I'm like
okay the most predictable innovation in
the world in my view is the AR glasses
have you talked about this on the
podcast before AR VR um of course a lot
but the AR is not as obvious actually
okay so AR glasses what what are AR
glasses so you take Stamp Set spectacles
Google Glass
um Apple's AR kit Facebook's Oculus
Quest 2 right or Meta Meta Quest 2
whatever okay you put those together and
what do you get you get
um something that has the form factor of
glasses that you'd wear outside okay
which
um can with the tap record or give you
Terminator Vision on something or with
another tap go totally dark and become
VR glasses okay so normal glasses AR
glasses VR glasses recording it says
multifunctional as your phone but it's
hands-free and you might actually even
wear it more than your phone in fact you
might be blind without your AR glasses
because uh you know one of the things
I've shown in the book early on are like
floating sigils did we talk did I show
you that so this
is a really important just visual
concept that right there shows with AR
kit you can see a Globe floating outside
okay secret societies are are returning
this is what nfts will become the the
nft locally on your crypto phone if you
hold it you can see the symbol and if
you don't you can't
by the way for people just listening
we're looking at a nice nature scene
where an artificially
created Globus floating in the air
yes but it's invisible if you're not
holding up the AR kit phone yes right so
so only you have a window into this
artificial world that's right and then
here is another thing which shows you
another piece of it
and this is using ens to unlock a door
so this is an nft use for something
different so the first one was using the
nft effectively to see something and the
second is using the nft to do something
okay so based on your on-chain
communication right
um You can unlock a door that's that's
the door to a room soon it could be a
door to a building it could be the gates
to a community it could be your digital
login okay and so amazing what this
means is basically a lot of these things
which are like individual pieces get
synthesized right and uh you eventually
have a digital just like you have a
digital currency or digital currencies
unify Concepts like uh obviously gold
stocks bonds derivatives every kind of
financial instrument plus Chuck E cheese
tokens Karma everything that's fungible
and transferable the digital passport
unifies your your Google style login
your private Keys your API Keys your
nfts your ens name your domain name all
those kinds of things and your key card
for your door and so on right so the AR
glasses are what probably I don't know
it'll be Facebook's version three year
version four apple is also working on
them Google's also working on them you
might just get a bunch of those models
at the same time it's like predicting
the iPhone just like you know Dorsey
knew that mobile was going to be big and
that's why he had 140 characters for
Twitter because there's like an SMS code
limitation and Twitter was started
before the iPhone AR glasses are an
incredibly predictable invention that
you can start thinking about the future
of social is in part in person okay and
it also means people might go outside
more why because you can't see a monitor
in the Sun but you can hit AR and maybe
you have a you know full screen thing
and you just like kind of you know move
your fingers or something and you can
tap you have to figure out the gesture
you don't have Gorilla arms maybe you do
have a keyboard outside or just even
like a
um you could even have a desk like this
you know if you had
um if you can touch type you could
imagine something where you look down
and you can see a keyboard with your AR
glasses and it registers it and then you
can type like this right and probably
you could have some AI that could you
know figure out what you meant rather
than what you were doing right okay so
that's Ai and social media that's AR and
social media but really
um one last thing I'll say which is a
non-obvious non-techological part is I
think we'll go from
very broad networks which are hundreds
of millions or billions of people like
Twitter and Facebook which have many
small communities in them to much
smaller networks that have a million or
10 million people but are much deeper
right in terms of their associate
affiliation right and this is the
long-term Trend in Tech because you're
going from eyeballs in the 1980s sorry
the eyeballs in the 1990s to daily
active users in the 2000s
two holders
in the 2010s so you go from just like oh
I'm just a lookie-loo to I'm logging in
every day to I'm holding a significant
percentage of my net worth
and then this decade is when the online
community becomes primary you're a
netizen the digital passport is your
main identity and so this is not see the
problem with Facebook or Twitter is it's
a bunch of different communities that
don't share the same values fighting
each other this brings us back to the
network state where you have one
Community with shared values shared
currency
um and it's full stack it's a it's a
social network and it's a cryptocurrency
and it's a co-living community and it's
a messaging app and it's in this and
it's a that and it's like Estonia you
know with a million people you can
actually build a lot of that full stack
that is starts to get to what I call a
network state
I feel like there should be like a a
standing Applause line here this is
brilliant you're an incredible person
this is an incredible conversation we
covered uh how to fix our government
looking at the future of governments uh
moving into Network State we covered how
to fix medicine FDA longevity that was
just like a stellar
description really I'll have to listen
to that multiple times to really think
and thank you for that especially in
this time where the lessons learned from
the pandemic
aren't clear to at least me and there's
a lot of thinking that needs to be done
there and then just a discussion about
how to fix social media and how to fix
money this was brilliant